one of the most common measures of pure
athletic performance is vertical jump
how high you can jump off the spot from
a standing position this shows your
explosive potential your ability to
recruit fast twitch muscle fiber however
whilst this is a very good test of
athletic potential it's not actually all
that useful in the real world how often
in sports or in martial arts or in any
other scenario do you need to just leap
off of both feet at once almost always
when we jump or when we kick we're
launching off of one foot and normally
with a run up up to that position so
training your ability to produce force
from one leg is probably more important
than training ability to produce force
through both legs when it comes to
jumping and athleticism not so true when
it comes to lifting things but if we're
talking about athletics and agility then
single leg strength becomes really
important even running involves exerting
force off of alternating legs now of
course you might think you can train
both legs at the same time and that
would be absolutely fine and it would
transfer over to single leg strength so
just squatting in theory should make you
jump higher from a single leg from a
running start and of course this is true
to an extent however it'll only get you
so far and training each leg
independently has a whole bunch of
potential advantages I recently had my
muscle mass scanned got a readout of the
weight and the distribution of muscle
mass across my body I found out that my
left leg was significantly smaller and
lighter than my right leg that was the
only imbalance I had and I suspect that
a lot of people are in the same boat
body builders know the importance of
training specifically for symmetry
that's why they won't just do bench
presses they'll do you know dumbbell
presses as well lots of unilateral
meaning one-armed and lots of bilateral
meaning both arms movements at the same
time to make sure they look the same on
either side otherwise it's very easy for
you to cheat and to help yourself on the
weak side by using more of the strong
side so in a squat you might push more
through the right leg than the left leg
without even realizing it and training
single leg strength will allow you to
overcome that imbalance that way you
know that both legs are as powerful
that'll improve your running speed and
it'll mean that you can jump from either
leg making you significantly quicker
significantly more agile in martial arts
in acrobatics in parkour everything at
the same time of course training single
leg string
this way will help me to balance and
help me to shift your center of gravity
which again is very important for
agility and for all-round performance
but on top of all that we Hill to have
something called the bilateral deficit
to consider the bilateral deficit
basically tells us that the amount of
force we can produce through a single
leg should be greater than the amount of
force we can produce through both legs
by which I mean that using a one-legged
leg press you should be able to produce
more than 60% of your leg press with
both legs
that's discounting things like balance
this wouldn't work for squat but where
all other things are equal you can exert
more strength through a single leg then
you can through both legs at the same
time and the reason for this probably
has to do with neural Drive that is that
when you exert all your force through a
single leg you can concentrate more
effort onto those muscles increase your
muscle fiber recruitment versus trying
to distribute your effort through two
legs so by training again focusing on
single legs at a time
we might be training our neural pathways
in a slightly different way and tapping
into extra strength and performance so
for that reason it's also probably a
good idea to make sure you're
occasionally using unilateral exercises
for your arms for your pecs etc in
general you should be using all your
body sometimes and just parts of your
body sometimes so again there are
benefits to isolation training and
finally the other reason I really like
single leg training and I think you
should incorporate it into your routines
is that it makes it much easier to
increase the challenge particularly with
bodyweight training I've been training a
lot from home lately as anyone who
follows me on Instagram knows and it's
quite difficult to train from home when
you're focusing on legs because you
can't get that same weight most people
don't have a squat rack in their home
most people don't have a barbell that
they can load up with 200 kilograms so
how are you going to create that
challenge at home one way to do this is
through plyometrics explosive jumping
and other moves like that and other ways
by controlling the weight using the kind
of old-time strongmen techniques that
I've talked about in the past and
another way is by using single leg
movements such as the one that gets
squat such as various types of walk and
all these things actually also really
fun ways to train your legs because for
most people training legs is a bit like
eating your vegetables it's the least
exciting thing to do that's especially
true when it comes to body weight but by
doing things on one leg by being
explosive you can actually find that a
leg workout can be quite fun so I have
shared
a full single leg workout routine over
at the Pioneer the link for that of
course we in the description down below
but here are a few exercises that you
can start using right away at home to
start training your single leg strength
as well so the first and most obvious
one is the single legged squat or the
pistol squat the pistol squat of course
means you've also got to keep your heel
on the floor and this is a great way of
training your mobility your flexibility
as well because it's quite tricky to do
that if you don't have full range of
motion at the same time you can of
course add a way to make it more
difficult by holding a kettlebell or by
having a barbell on your shoulders etc
the lunge of course is one of the
best-known single leg exercises and one
that people commonly use and you can
also do a lunch walk so walking around
the garden and in fact any kind of
loaded carry anything where you're
carrying a really heavy weight and just
walking with it is great for your single
leg strength because of course you're
going to be on a single leg at various
point throughout that movement and at
the same time you're engaging your core
and you're balancing I did a whole video
on loaded carries and why they're so
good for you a similar move to the lunge
that I also really like is the side
squat and here you'll basically holding
weight as normal and then you're
stepping out to one side and then
plunging down on that one leg and so
basically it's kind of a cross between a
squat and a lunge that's a great way to
build up to the pistol squat if you
can't do it right away and of course
again you can add more weight if you
want to increase the challenge you've
obviously got your calf raises and
single legged calf raises are almost a
requirement to make that move difficult
enough I've also talked in the past
about calf jumps I really like this
exercise it basically means that you
keep your knees entirely straight and
you launch yourself off of just your
calves so you're really engaging the
curves and the feet in order to exert
that power and I'm gonna be doing my
video on ninja training very soon and
apparently some people think that ninjas
might have used a similar technique in
order to build up their leg strength so
of course you can do calf jumps from a
single leg and you can even make this
another form of travel by doing calf
jumps on one leg all the way down the
garden another really good one you can
do with no weight though is a squat walk
basically you're staying really low to
the ground as though you're squatting
and then walking your way around the
garden and you can combine all these
into a kind of circuit or kind of
mechanical drop set you can get a really
intense workout on your legs wherever
you are using just your bodyweight by
focusing on just the leg at the time
there are ton more exercises of course
that you can use and I'd love you to
share them down in the comments below
and I'll be addressing this topic in the
future soon I do have plans to make a
video on jumping height in general so
I'll be discussing that more then I hope
you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like please share it around like
I say please comment down below all that
stuff really helps me out
massively got lots more content on the
way soon I'm gonna be doing a video on
the life of Bruce Lee one of my learning
from legends videos as well as Houdini
I'm gonna be doing ninja training like I
said and lots more ancient warrior
training I'm gonna do a video on Qi
control and what actually is in martial
arts whether it's real whether it's not
etc I'll be doing a video on personality
and how that affects your focus as well
as your physical performance lots more
stuff in the pipeline for the new year
so that all sounds good then please
stick around and I'll see you next time
Merry Christmas and bye for now